foreign
[Music]
senior programmer at film independent
and welcome to this film independent
presents q a for the new Fox Searchlight
film Rye Lane by director Rayne Allen
Miller special thanks to our lead
sponsor hfpa our media sponsor KCRW and
our virtual screenings partner Vision
media and now please welcome to this q a
director Rayne Allen Miller and actress
David Johnson and Vivian opara hello
everybody
thank you for joining us
thank you
um
so let's let's start by talking about
rylane so I'm not sure that very many
Americans this movie takes place in a
very specific place I'm not sure that
very many Americans know what rylane is
where rylane is can you talk about
rylane
um well well Ryan is basically in
Peckham which is in South London and
most of the film is set in Peckham and
in Brixton brixton's actually South West
but they're both pretty iconic places in
in kind of different ways
um but you know it's a it's a place that
there's a few things there's a few TV
shows and films that show it but it's
often shown in a slightly more gritty
way and so this film sort of shines a
more positive light on it
yeah at times I felt like
rylane was the other character in this
film and um the characters really felt
at home in it and part of it and I
really like that it showcased this place
that I felt like I hadn't seen before in
a film
um so do you want to talk about
um
what inspired the film how you got the
script how you came to direct it
yeah sure I am
I kind of went into you know I always
imagined I'd have written my first
feature film but I got sent the script
and I was on the train and I just like
laughed publicly and sort of embarrassed
myself slightly and I was kind of like
okay this is a sign like let me see you
know let me see where this goes
um and what was nice about it was
it's a pretty simple idea you know it's
two people walking around getting to
know each other and for a director that
is kind of the perfect canvas you know
to really put your stamp on something I
really enjoyed the dialogue I really
liked the characters but I also felt
like there was space for me to develop
it
um and I developed it with the writers
you know for two years and um it was
originally set in Camden which is north
London
um and I decided that it should be in
South London one because I know it
really well I moved there when I was 12.
I'm originally from Manchester
um and it's it's a really special place
um and you know it it's just got so much
soul and it feels like such a great
backdrop for for to have two characters
walking around all day you know you need
a place that has soul and is in a way
um the third character in the movie so
it just felt like the right place for it
um talk about
um if you can working for so this is
your first feature film right
yeah
talk about the experience of of making
your first feature
um it's an interesting one like I kind
of always imagined when I'd go into my
first feature that I'd be freaking out
and not really know what I'm doing but
weirdly I was so sure and so clear and I
think that's kind of the job as a
director I guess like if a director
tells up on certain they don't really
know what's going on then what on Earth
is that film gonna be
um so you know it was kind of amazing it
was like I I guess coming from
commercials and like having made quite a
lot of commercials music videos I do
have a lot of confidence in my vision
and I and I really like my own taste you
know and so going into it was was
actually really fun and I was really
lucky because I had quite a lot of trust
you know
um BBC BFI and Searchlight actually just
really trusted me and really liked all
of the decisions
um that I made so it was it was a really
special experience and sometimes I'd be
on set and look around and be like okay
where's the person that's going to like
tell me that like I should probably
shoot an over-the-shoulder shot and they
weren't there thank god
um
so yeah no it was it was a joy and
obviously like
made
150 times easier by brilliant actors you
know sitting right here
um so yeah working with them was a
complete Joy but the process was a joy
and I felt very trusted
so yeah let's let's talk to your actors
um for you two what was it about the
script and this director that made you
want to do the project let's start with
David
well that's always good to start with me
50 isn't it yeah exactly exactly well
there you go uh no no I guess I guess
you know
um first of all and I got the script
throughout the time when I was getting a
decent amount of other things through
and
a lot of the things I think what people
tend to do is they they see you in one
thing and then they kind of like go oh
that's what you do so we give you tons
more of the same and that's not really
the kind of actor that I want to be
especially now uh so taking on something
that feels like a challenge is really
important to me so anyway this film came
about and I you know honestly I read it
this romantic comedy set in Beckham and
it just made me laugh that made me laugh
I thought it was absolutely funny and
hilarious and coming from London myself
um it just felt like a London that I
recognized and I was like oh wait
where's the uh where's the darkness in
this and they're like oh well there's
not and that and that was quite special
to me and then obviously you find out
that range threat to me who I just think
is a Visionary
um it's weird because she's sitting
there isn't it but you know she knows
she knows she knows all this and then
Vivian me and Vivian who I just think is
absolutely brilliant and makes it easy
to do what I want to do and
um yeah it kind of felt like a bit of a
Dream Team yeah
um yeah thanks a lot
um
for me I just read the script
found it hilarious was like this is
really cool
um I was kind of invigorated by like the
idea of a female character who's like
unapologetically messy and
um curious and impulsive I found her
really chaotic to read on the page but I
was just like this I imagined it to be
like a lot of fun to bring to life and I
thought I was curious about like what
the emotional reality was behind her
character like that was and I thought
that would be just like a fun challenge
to like sink my teeth into as well and
then I checked out rain's work and I was
like this is like you know you can you
can look at someone's working like this
person's a nerd for what they do like
you're like a World Builder everything
you do is so rich and
it's I was like okay like I wanna do
this and then I get to the audition and
I see like you know it's like dark skin
people up for the roles and I'm like
these guys are committed to making like
a rom-com with two dark skin needs
they're tapped in like I get they want
to tell like a truthful just honest
portrayal of like a cool story here
um and I was into it and I was hungry
for the part
success
[Laughter]
[Music]
so uh this film played premiered in
Sundance earlier this year did the did
the three of you all get to go to Park
City Utah
yeah and experience tell us about your
experience at um Sundance taking this
phone to Sundance and your first
audiences
that was mad it was so weird
[Music]
it's all of our first feature so it's
like to have to make a film your first
film is not and then when you love films
to go to Sundance just bad experiences
and incredible and to go to sunlights
with your first film it's just like this
is too much going on now I can't process
yeah it was just surreal like absolutely
well and and also I think that you know
like like we've said we we all really
love
film like not just film but like good
films so we'd be on set and we'd be in
between tapes and we'd just be like what
do you think about this film and then
we'll talk you know like kind of like
the talks that you do at Sundance
um to then goes like a film festival
which for me feels like it's so
authentically about like good movies was
like yeah it was I I yeah I remember my
Asian calling me and being like you're
going to Sundance like throwing my phone
and be like thank you that's so cool
yeah
this is always good to be a Sundance
Film and we all kind of like talked
about that I think when we were making
it it was like it was it was the
festival that we all wanted it to go to
and it felt so sorry it was also amazing
like projecting a film that is set in
South London in like the mountains of
Utah like how it was so surreal yeah
walking around in like jackets being
really cold and seeing like snowy
mountains and being like Oh my God our
film's premiering here this is so cool
it was great
oh I think David mentioned when he was
reading the script being struck you know
waiting for something dark to happen but
being struck by how positive it was and
I'm just wondering
because I felt that way too watching it
I was just like
I'm in love with love again I believe I
believe in love again
um
did were you all conscious of that when
you were making this film
um were you all conscious of wanting to
make
this a film that celebrates human beings
and human relationships
I think like when you're making a film
that is
genuinely like really truthful about
like zooming in on something which is
quite mundane like two people talking
you can see how easy it is to then
romanticize your your own life and like
the Simplicity in life and I think that
is easy to that's super endearing to
watch happen on screen so I think um
yeah like
it it just the the concept the idea was
just easy to fall in love because when
you zoom in on something as simple as a
conversation between two people and two
people building a bond it's like
special and feels yeah great so yeah it
was quite nice wasn't it to just sort of
like unapologetically make something
happy like people often say what do you
want people to feel when they leave the
cinema and it's like happy and that and
that actually feels quite amazing
yeah but like it you know in a way like
it's there's so much out there that
makes us think it makes us feel and yeah
that is so important but this film like
isn't super political it's joyful and
right now like we kind of need that and
so we were all quite passionate you know
and we all reference loads of like
really serious important work that we
love but this film isn't that and I
think we were quite excited by the idea
of embracing Joy yeah yeah because it's
Joy is great right
he doesn't want to be happy yeah and you
know you were not even on that point as
well like you you make
sure
yeah
in cursive it's like a horrible
Instagram post with someone really
annoying and I just said it but it's
cliche for a reason because it's true
it's true yeah it is true and also I
think if you take
if you um if you stop and you think
about also like you know why we're like
oh it's so joyous it's also because
it you know it's true like you know it
doesn't it's it's not it's not um
hyperbolic in a way like it's like we
can be go through a heartbreak and still
find Joy on the other side and it just
be a film about joy and it still feel
like Peckham it still feel like South
London it still feel like young people
falling in and out of love and and be
completely joyous and true and I think
um in the wrong hands that wouldn't be
the case in in the case of having
someone like rain she she really was uh
uh very conscious of making that and
like delicately putting that into our
environment and our psyche is going yeah
like it just it can be right because
it's because it's true you know and I'm
like oh yeah but oh it looks exactly
like well I know I'm yeah so let's just
do that sure I mean it's there wasn't
nothing um there was nothing that felt
fake about the joy you know anyway yeah
David said to me yesterday he was like
you never asked us to smile remember
that's what I mean
I hate smiling I hate cheesy Smiles at
the worst you know where it's like can
you just yeah it has to be real and
natural but that's exactly that's
exactly what I meant right because I'm
never gonna smile around you ever again
I like a real smile I like a real smile
exactly it was real
you'll do one later when I make you
laughing
there it is
boyfriend the energy
I make you laugh a little smiles
I'm wondering if the three of you feel
that um there's
uh a lot or a little about this film
that people will say it represents your
generation
um
represents how your generation views
love
I was just thinking about this you know
because it's the the anniversary of a
lot of John Hughes films and John Hughes
were like was like the Teenage Love
movies of my generation
um like Pretty in Pink and Breakfast
Club and movies like that
I'm wondering if you feel that there's
anything about the movie that makes
you feel like it represents this
particular generation and how they view
relationships
your generation guys I'm way older than
that no no I mean I mean do you know
what you know what I think I think that
there's there's um
it's really flattering and people talk
about this film is like
I don't know like a a new Reinventing a
rom-com or like showing a different side
of like our experience that hasn't been
shown but this is all great and you know
let these quotes carry on flowing in
because I'm loving them but equally like
it's all kind of in retrospect isn't it
like we don't quite a know I'm pretty
sure like The Breakfast Club which is an
amazing film and John Hughes who's an
amazing director didn't know what he was
probably doing or maybe he did because
I'm pretty sure rain kind of knew I
think she knew yeah well that's my job
and she's good and she's so good at it
but you know but but what I'm trying to
say is that yeah we I think you know you
kind of don't know what what's going to
be generational you just kind of make a
film and hope it's going to be good I
think you're right I totally agree I
think there's that thing where you you
don't go into it going like this is
about our generation like I think you
represent I imagine especially as actors
like you go I am representing this
character I don't think you're going to
go and this is a piece about this
generation I mean maybe some directors
do that and and plan for that but I
think for all of us it was about the
characters and that day and and but just
being really disciplined about do doing
just this to that day like and and sort
of making that feel as authentic and as
and is sort of elevated in the right
places as possible and I think when you
do that if you do if you approach things
authentically then they do represent
what they're supposed to represent which
is
a generation of young people having a
nice day
um
yeah
I don't know if that made any sense
because would you could you could have
called the film young people having a
nice day I'm glad you didn't but that
would be that would be so funny
I actually love that yeah guys
you imagine simplifying it to that
Beyond them having an having a nice day
is as simple
I love this Dijon kind of genre of the
walking in the walking and talking movie
people getting to know each other and it
makes me think of um Barry Jenkins
medicine for melancholy
um I'm wondering you talk about movies
that you were inspired by
what are films and filmmakers that that
you're all inspired by
um
rain Allen
obviously obviously rain is Heller and
inspiring
um not just because of what we've made
but also because of how she treated us
and was really able to like give give me
freedom and I think I'm a kind of actor
that kind of needs it I need to like uh
take something and make it my own then
flip it and she really gave us that
space so right but I mean I mean I mean
you know there's so many Barry Jenkins
is incredible I think Steve McQueen's
quite special and
um but I also have that Gaspar no way I
quite like a lot of
French Cinema that things that can be
done but also can feel elevated and true
and give space for
um a new experience or something
different
um I quite I quite like those yeah I
love a World Builder that's what I love
rain
um so I would say like
you've named you've named The Heavy hers
but like you know like you're God like
now having to like Michelle gondry has
like a really childlike dreamlike
approach to to film
um which I adore same as obviously like
Tarantino
um
God like gamma Del Toro is just the best
like at creating worlds
um yeah Jordan peel like
so people that are uncompromising on
their Vision
um having that type of Artistic
integrity and seeing the payoff like and
I'm I hope you feel it because that's
how I feel this film has been made so
amazing because you just had such a
specific Vision that you didn't kind of
move from and you honored your own like
yeah your own author and the film's good
thank you no worries
um so yeah I guess that's usually who
I'm drawn to directors wise
yeah they've named them all now so
no I think um
I think this I mean there's so many
directions that I find inspiring I mean
especially I think for me Steve McQueen
is it's interesting because obviously
he's you know you wouldn't I don't think
you'd ever make any comparisons to
rylane in any of his work but what I
love about Steve McQueen is that he kind
of just wants to put something out there
that he and it doesn't matter what
medium it's it's in like I just think
it's unbelievable that he won the Turner
prize and what an Oscar and he just
makes what he wants to make and he's so
strong with that but he's also from like
you know he's he's he's from like I
don't know whereabouts in London he's
from but he's from like a fairly
normal background he went to a normal
school and he's just epic and for me
that's really inspiring you know it's
there's you don't as a director you
don't really get that many British other
British directors that you can look at
and go I've had a similar experience and
therefore I could maybe they've had a
similar experience to me therefore maybe
I could do that and Steve McQueen
definitely made me feel like maybe I
could do that maybe I could win an Oscar
yeah you know
um
so he's definitely an inspiration but
hard to list Jordan peel again like a
true Visionary
um also love Mighty Scorsese because he
you know his New York same as Spike Lee
like their New York it's a Spike Lee's
New York it's a Martin scorsese's New
York it's so
the way they kind of
own their yeah their areas is just so
wonderful
I love that I love it
another one I think of British uh TV and
film no I think of you I think of Steve
McQueen I think of Michaela Cole yeah I
I love that that's that's this
generation of British film and
television I'm really excited by it and
I love that in the United States we we
get a lot of that television and film
um
and I just think that this this movie is
so exciting and I'm so excited that our
members get to see it because yes it is
a rom-com but I would say
it's better it's way better than most
rom-coms
[Applause]
you know
we get a ton of those like crazy
Christmas rom-coms here in the United
States and it was just a refreshing not
knowing anything about you all and not
knowing anything about this film and
watching and just being like
feeling so excited so I just want to say
thanks so much for all your hard work on
it
um when is this coming out in the United
States the end of the month
31st isn't it I think yeah on Hulu yeah
well I'm really excited to see what you
all do next and um speaking of do you
guys have anything in the works for the
next project rain do you have it
upcoming I'm I'm writing a film
um and
TV show in development
but that's all I can really say for now
so hopefully
that will get going look if I would do
it another one it's not a rom-com though
guys sorry
this one is not gonna have people
smiling in it
no smiling
um yeah I'm writing so see how that all
pans out I got a series coming out
um on Skyrim and by the right of the
capture called Ben Shannon um
in a couple of months time called then
you run which is Fab and yeah loads of
interesting
stuff in front of me just trying to pick
the right next move what about you
you know I feel very uh lucky and
working hard and I'm I've got two films
I'm about to do and one of them is the
um the new um alien
um uh so that should be cool yeah
oh wow congratulations thank you that's
amazing it's exciting
all right well thank you so much for um
Coming to talk about rileen I wish you
the best of luck with the film and
um
I just love it thank you so much thank
you
[Music]